live to youtube
and via the council's website the
meeting is also being recorded for the
purposes of
the minutes i have been advised that the
live stream is now up and running
if for any reason the public can no
longer hear or see the meeting over the
live stream we will adjourn
until the connection has been
reestablished
can i ask the governance officer to
explain the procedure of the meeting and
to confirm
the members and officers present yes
thank you chair
uh just to confirm with uh martin
derbyshire has the live feed
no starters
[Music]
right thank you uh yes chair in terms of
the membership today and apologies if i
miss anyone off
we have councillor and cliff yourself uh
councillor armitage
councillor barker councillor k bone
councillor
p bone councillor cooper councillor
cornwell
councillor cupid councillor dale
councillor dayton councillor evans
councillor angelique foster councillor
mark foster
councillor jay fernell councillor hall
councillor hancock
councillor hartshorne councillor hill
councillor holmes councillor huckabee
councillor hutchinson councillor jones
councillor canyon councillor kerry
councillor lewis councillor liggett
councillor lilly councillor morley
councillor parkin council pickering
councillor potts councillor powell
council reader councillor renick
councillor ridgeway rowe
councillor rouse councillor ruff
councillor shipman councillor tate
councillor thacker and councillor welton
are there any other members here of uh
noctur called out
councillor gomez thank you chad
councillor cloth as well
councillor whitehead right thank you
okay yes we've got you down
okay uh in terms of the officer support
today
um well obviously um i'm back to the
meeting alan marr
but the principal officers will be
supporting you
will be uh lee hicken the joint director
of corporate resources and the head of
paid service
jill callingham director of growth and
economic development
karen hansen joint director of
environment and enforcement
jane dethick head of finance and
resources
and service sternberg joint head of
corporate governance
and monitoring officer the process for
the meeting or the procedure for the
meeting will be very similar um to your
previous uh council meetings held
virtually
first of all can members keep on keep
their cameras on
throughout the meeting and observe the
rules of procedure
and standing orders to indicate that you
wish to speak
please raise your hands or write speak
in the chat function keep your
microphone off
until you're invited to speak if you're
having any technical issues then please
let one of the governance team now
and there'll be various members of the
governance team who'll be here to
support you today
thank you chair thank you
are there any apologies uh well we've
received an apology from councillor b
reicher chair i i believe um
councillor elliot uh has also messaged
um to try and get onto the meeting but
he's struggling so
if a member of the governor's team could
please send him the uh
we send in the link that'll be much
appreciated thank you so
chef thank you
councillor jane barry did you get jane
barry jane barry i'll put that in now
is that in terms of apologies members
and no further apologies chair
thank you members of interest should
have declared them to the governance
manager in advance of the meeting
however i will ask again
can members please indicate if they have
any interest
to declare
none of being received here
can we approve the minutes of the last
meeting as true and an accurate record
proposing them
is that councilor parker um proposing
no i think councillor parker which is to
make a point
yeah i just want do you want to move on
first alex and bring your
which way around is it i i i i'm happy
to move them yes
uh yeah thank you
and the seconder please
we're now going to commence voting sorry
can i just just make a point on the
minute sorry
uh we uh our group
we don't really want to uh agree to
these minutes because
uh i know it's a new point but council
was at that meeting
and he was invited to that meeting and
he did vote at that meeting
and his attendance is not recorded or
his apologies
uh anywhere to be seen just just because
his name's
uh not in those minutes uh
we we won't uh be agreeing to him thank
you
any other speakers um
can i ask us following that point chair
um why has his name been removed if he
was there and he was voting
um sorry i hope i'm not too close to
this um
mr hunt ceased to be a member of the
council through non-attendance
under section 85 of the local government
act and although he was
physically at a meeting he was no longer
a councillor so he wouldn't be recorded
as a counsellor
yeah that we'll revisit that in a minute
if that's okay
sarah on the the next item cheers thank
you
we are now going to commence voting
governance officer will issue
a poll now
that's before i'm sorry i
can't say
hi sorry it's councillor roger hall
point of order please
has the poll been sent to everybody
because
people that weren't at the meeting would
not be able to vote am i correct in
understand
is that my correct understanding
[Music]
oh chair um members who were not at mm
at the previous meeting they're still
able to actually vote on the the minutes
okay thank you i just wanted to clarify
can we add two from the chamber four
please
yeah okay that makes 27 votes for so
that's carried
uh i think councillor bergen wishes to
speak yes
council perkin thank you chair i found
the answer to
that you just gave to the council of all
a bit um confusing
uh how can somebody who wasn't present
at the meeting
uh vote to accept the minutes of that
meeting as a true record
there's a bit of an oxymoron type of
thing in there surely to goodness
well it's certainly obvious being custom
and practiced within local government
that members can approve the minutes of
a previous meeting
so i'm really just going on the basis of
the precedent
it is the normal sorry sarah sternberg
monitoring officer it is normal to
allow everybody to vote in the um on the
minutes
different from moving and seconding and
i was also add that in these days of
virtual meetings somebody might not have
been there but might have been watching
councillor armitage uh thank you chair
i wasn't uh able to vote i don't know
why didn't come up on my screen
alan is there a problem with polls
[Music]
not that i'm aware of sure um amy um
are there any issues no
um it didn't look like it um
42 votes were made for it so we can add
yours on cancer armitage
um on top of that if you'd like us to
yes i would uh and i i would vote
fall
okay colleagues last week i marked on
this today
for the two two-minute silence and laid
a wreath here at mill lane
i was joined by a councillor of thakur's
vice chair and armed forces champion
as well as councillor dale as leader of
the council
on this important day we pause to
reflect and mark the end of the first
world war
and to remember the sacrifice made by so
many in conflicts over the last 100
years
i invite councillor dale to give the
leaders announcements
thank you chair um can i start by
saying a huge thank you to the amazing
and hard-working
uh staff at northeast derbyshire
district council
for absolutely everything that they've
been doing over the past few weeks in
adapting
uh to the recent changes in restrictions
and the impact of
increased covert rates in northeast
derbyshire they remain an absolute
credit to this organization
and the resilience and adaptability
they've shown has been truly excellent
uh and in saying this i'd also like to
echo the same sentiments to staff
from richmond homes who continue to work
very closely with us
i'm also very grateful to members from
across the political spectrum for the
support they've shown to the council at
this very challenging time
our viper meetings continue to be very
productive and i welcome the import from
all those around the table to help
ensure that we are doing all we can to
support our residents and businesses
to respond to this pandemic um on the
subject of businesses i know that many
of us will be receiving inquiries about
about support grants from local
businesses
and i'm pleased to inform you that
finance officers are working extremely
hard to get the three different grant
schemes established
and they are hoping to go but live very
cert very soon
as you'll all know a few weeks ago
northeast derbyshire was a significant
cause for concern with the highest
and most rapidly rising covered rates in
the county
uh decisive action was taken to increase
the level of restrictions in our area on
the 15th of october
now clearly decisions of this nature
where there is an obvious impact on
businesses the local economy
and the way that people live their lives
are never easy
but we are now beginning to see some
glimmers of lights
and cases leveling off in northeast
derbyshire ahead of several other areas
of the county
but we absolutely must not be complacent
and we need to continue to follow the
national restrictions very closely
and collectively all do our bits to get
back on top of this dreadful virus
while coronavirus continues to disrupt
our way of life it's absolutely
essential
that we don't let it disrupt our
progress in achieving our ambitions for
the council in this district
i'm pleased that despite the challenges
we face we're continuing to deliver
quality services to the people of
northeast derbyshire
and to pick out just a few highlights
from the past few months
i'm really pleased that we've secured a
green homes grant from the government
worth
575 000 pounds to help us to to
refurbish 110 homes in mickley
as part of a wider 3 million investment
program
the funding will be used to add
insulation to the properties reducing
their carbon footprint
and the cost of energy bills for our
residents on that note
work is also progressing on our thank
thanks a ton campaign
which we'll be launching in january to
encourage residents to help do their bit
in reducing our district's carbon
emissions
last month together with the clay
crosstown board we submitted the town
investment plan to government
as our ambitious bid for up to 25
million pounds
to transform the prospects of this
community we've also hit the ground
running with delivering the plan
having received an early grant of 500
000 pounds to kick-start some of the
projects
and officers will continue so officers
will cover the plan in more detail
during the presentation later on in the
agenda
and finally i'm very pleased that
cabinet has recently given approval to
invest
in both our planning and environmental
health services
this includes expanding our planning
enforcement team and recruiting
conservation and arboricultural
expertise
and in environmental health investing in
a special covered support team
and additional offices to support
residents and businesses through this
pandemic
before i finish chair i would just like
to also inform members that
as our next full council meeting is not
until february
and due to some additional items of
business that will need approval
it may be necessary to host an
additional full council meeting
in mid-december or early january a date
hasn't yet been set but assuming that it
is required
governance will contact members as soon
as possible
to provide more details thank you very
much chair
thank you counselor dale i can't confirm
that no public questions have been
submitted
so we will we shall move on to the next
item
count chair
am i permitted to ask the leader a
couple of questions if that's all right
councillor dale are you yeah i'm happy
to happen to try and answer any of the
councils questions yeah um i'm just
wondering you're talking about your
viper meetings um are you given updates
on the actual figures of
um the people in northeast derbyshire
who have contracted
um kobe 19 and things like that and the
amount of deaths
because i've got the figures in front of
me if you haven't
and also just on the side i noticed that
um
car parking looks as if it's going to be
reinstigated again at
the hospitals and i think i would like
as
leader of you as leader of this council
to wholeheartedly go against that for
the time being um maybe write a letter
to
whoever deals with it the hospitals
because like me
we're going in there dealing with
critical care you know itu hdu
people with kobe 19 and to think that we
have to pay to park
to save people's lives at this
particular time i think is quite
difficult so i'm just asking on the side
if you could help in that please
okay thank you yes um the first question
yes i
attend the local outbreak engagement
board uh meetings and do
get um some oversight of the figures um
obviously there is always a degree of
lag in the figures of a few days as
we know um but the latest meeting i
attended was late
last week and it was clear from the
evidence of the past
couple of weeks that there is a leveling
off that we
we aren't seeing in some other areas
that didn't move to tier two
um so as i say
it's uh it's glimmers of light we are by
no means there yet until
uh the work that we need to do and we
absolutely all must be
uh not be complacent in any way uh about
the work that there is still to do to
bring down rates in the district
uh but but i think it is important that
we knowledge that the decision to move
to timothy
i believe was the right one uh not an
easy decision as i say but i do believe
it was the right one
and has helped us to move uh in the
right sort of direction
the second point around hospital parking
absolutely more than happy to pick that
up with you
um outside the meeting council ridgeway
and see if we can
we can lend support from the district to
um to any uh any lobbying on on that
issue
thank you for the meeting thank you
thank you please note
that an update appendix 2 was circulated
in the supplementary pack
i now invite the monitoring officer to
present the report
thank you chairman this is item seven
the appointments to committees and
advisory groups this is a standard
report brought before members when the
need arises to reconsider
proportionality on committees
when there is a change in political
balance appendix 1 is the agreed best
fit for the authorities agreed to annual
council
with one change as a result of the
proportionality change
this change is to reduce the number of
labour members on standards committee by
one
and this would remain as a vacancy until
the proportionality is considered again
after a by-election or a shift in
political balance for any reason
appendix ii as the chair said in the
supplementary pack
is the appointments to keep this leader
and your counsel and meant by council at
a later meeting
and bought again today to affect the
change to standards committee
no other amendments are suggested at
this stage
however this is an opportunity to make
any changes that political groups wish
someone to propose the recommended
action
i'm happy to uh propose jared that's
okay
thank you is there a second
i think councillor armitage is
indicating
thank you does anyone wish to speak on
this item
oh i've got my hand up jay i don't know
if you can see it
yeah councillor barker and mitchell
barker and councillor
thank you
thanks sarah for that uh as alluded to
earlier
we are really disappointed that we've
arrived at this situation
uh we're hoping that that we won't have
to to go through this process
uh i think most people know clive
council hunt
and the situation he's been through he's
had severe medical problems
uh and and again it
it's been a funny period we've had
colvin and we've had one or two other
things
happened you know in this period i was
advised and i and
and i've got other other people who
think
that that clive was his time was in
until october this year
i was told by governance people on
several occasions
that clive was still okay uh
there is a contentious thing that it
maybe
he wasn't but i think the understanding
was he were until october
again going back we've had the culvert
thing that's been difficult for
everybody
in fact where the council meeting
cancelled clive was invited
uh to the meeting as we as we've alluded
to in september
he wasn't told he couldn't come to that
meeting he sat through all that meeting
so i assumed that everybody all the
governance people
assumed that it was still okay to be at
that meeting
uh and again it's
it's a disappointing situation and
it's i know clive's upset about it and
one thing or another
and we could put the blame on him he
should have kept a check
but it doesn't feel right it doesn't
feel right this doesn't
and i'd ask that that we can revisit
that decision
and i know legally that there might be
an issue with that and i'm sure
uh sarah will tell us that but there are
some questions that that still needed
need to be asked there's several
questions been raised
on a different at a different level uh
that have not been answered yet
uh and i'd like at this point
to to ask you to go back and revisit
that if there's any chance
because this can't be election until
next may anyway
uh it's just a request uh and i'd i'd be
interested to see what
uh what sarah's got to say on that you
know the legalities and
again i just i just find it difficult
uh especially if people that know cliff
well thanks anyway thank you
thanks chair sarah sternber monitoring
officer uh council barca actually
alluded it to him
to it in what he's just said it's not a
decision
it is the effect of the law section 85
local
government act means that if there's
non-attendance the member ceases to be a
member
that's not a decision that's just a fact
in terms of
misunderstandings and what people may or
may not have been told
i will counsel barca i'll give you a
ring and we'll have a discussion about
that
and try to find out what happened but
that would not affect
the position in law
thank you councillor rita
yeah i just wanted to echo pretty much
what council barca said and
again so i'm very disappointed with that
response
um you know at some point councillor
hunt should have been contacted
he was really ill we're in an
unprecedented time of covid
i'm not sure what the rules and
regulations are around that with
with coronavirus i know that a number of
councils
have sort of wavered that kind of rule
you know in terms of the corona virus
because you know not all councils can
meet
so i would like some more clarity really
on how that decision was made
who made that decision where did it come
from
and and just get some more clarity for
our group really
sarah sternberg as i said
previously it was no decision it is the
operation of the law
if there's been non-attendance the
member ceases to be a member
however i also did say that i would
contact councillor barker as leader of
the labour group
to talk about what he has and has not
been told along the way
and that is a separate issue and it
would not go to whether or not the
member
ceases to be a member it would only go
to how it's been dealt with
so to sum up it's not a decision so it
can't be revisited as a decision
it is the operation of the law
okay sarah it's still it's still
disappointing i think there is
there is a bit of a gray area there but
uh
we'll have a talk about it and and
that's it
point me yeah i'd like to make a point
speaking believe councillor pickering's
answer pickering
thank you uh the point the point i'd
like to make yes
um as sarah says it is an application of
the law
but it seems that there's some latitude
in that
in that elected members in this chamber
can vary that because on both sides from
conservative members and
from clive's point of view we've
approved six months dispensations not
three months and clive's original one
was for
six months and that's the good faith
that we've operated in
and suddenly without any consultation
it's now been determined that the law
says three months
uh and clive's now being excluded from
this council
well that three months was up when he
was invited
as a councillor to come to the last
meeting
he was accepted into that meeting as a
councillor
his name has been now deliberately
missed off the attendance
and he voted as a councillor so there is
some latitude in that law in that this
chamber can vote on that
and i can't remember voting that clyde's
last period of
absence was only three months because i
would have been moving in this chamber
that it'd be
six months and i think i would have got
a lot of support from all sides in this
chamber
but clive to have a six-month
dispensation so it might be that you're
applying the law but where there are
grey areas of the law can be changed or
determined by the elect by the elected
members
we should be looking at that or
investigating why that's not being done
in this case
thank you council cornwall
yes i want to um reiterate what steve
just said i think an investigation needs
to have been happening
if a decision has been made and the law
is the law
okay but he came to a previous meeting
and he voted at that meeting at that
point
the law should have been applied and it
wasn't
so nobody informed him nobody informed
the leader it just happened in the
background
at a very awkward time
i.e when we were trying to have an
emergency meeting
so i suspect something happened
and somebody did some looking and
realized that
he may not be allowed to attend
so i really would like an investigation
on this issue
sarah sternberg it is ultimately the
members responsibility
to ensure that they attend within six
months
so it's as i say their responsibility
it's not something we
need or should under the legislation
tell them about
i've offered to talk to council barker
about what happened and who said what
where and when
in terms of the emails that were flying
around
but that wouldn't affect the legal
position either
nor nothing can be done under the
legislation in retrospect once the
member ceases
to have attended for six months that is
it you can't do
even you as members cannot do anything
it is just the legal position but as i
said i have offered to talk to council
barker about the position
and about what was said
can i just say he was ill he was not
in a position where he could fight his
case
he was unwell therefore
couldn't contact you and couldn't
discuss it
counselor ann [ __ ]
thank you chair i i would particularly
like to raise my concerns here i i
recall
voting to approve a dispensation for
councillor hunt for six months
i certainly don't recall voting one for
for three months
and i think i don't think this should be
a private conversation with council
barca to be both at the truth or
this needs to be a full report to this
council as to how
councillor hunt was here as to how he
was voting and then all of a sudden
we're told he's no longer a counselor
somewhere along the lines behind the
scenes section 85 has been applied
and i respect what uh
what uh what the monitoring officer is
saying that it is
it is a matter of legality but we
haven't applied that law properly if
we've allowed him to vote in the first
place
and we need a proper account to this
council not just a private discussion
with council mark and no disrespect to
either person involved in that
council ridgeway uh yes i i totally
agree with
everything that everybody said and if i
recall i'm sure
before we have that actually extended
beyond six months for people to
um you know have have a six month
extension
another another six month extension and
i'm sure at some time
we should have had or you know
somebody should the monitoring officer
or somebody should have asked us to look
at that
so i again i think it's it's it's been
very ill managed and i think um
an investigation does need to be looked
at and if it was happening on the other
side of the table i would be sitting
here saying the same
thing it applies to both sides of the
table both political parties and i think
you know something needs to be looked at
as i say i know that we have extended
you know
um dispensation for people for sickness
longer than six months before so i think
it needs to be looked at
can you see me i'm sat here waving me
and like a fool
it's going to hell
can i speak now
right yes sir can i say and and i say
this to the leader
and hope he can listen and do something
what a disgusting way to treat
a counselor that was seriously ill
that he could not answer any questions
from governance
about the the time it was off or
anything
we was led to be understand that
councillor hunt was okay
for another six month and if that's not
the case
they should have stopped him immediately
he came to that meeting
and said sorry councillor hunt you are
no longer a councillor and you will have
to leave
that didn't happen now but i don't care
in governance
who's to blame for this but somebody is
to blame
and i just think what an appalling way
to treat
a man that was seriously ill we would
not we would not do it
to any other counsellor whichever party
we are
and we've done it in the past we've
extended
and extended not because the council was
ill
because when a member of their family
was ill
it's still the same thing it say
i must ask counselor dale to take a look
at this
and see what's gone wrong here because
something has
and and it needs it needs a plan and it
needs to put in right
councillor renwick yeah just i'd just
like to add my support to
any any investigation report coming to
other standards or or to this council if
not just to
rule out any political interference from
the conservative group uh the council
hunt is actually
a member of the parish council and we
keep good track of his
um you know his right to vote his right
to be on that council so uh just to the
avoidance of any doubt um this is no
there's no political gun on here
i'd like that's also to be included in
the report thank you
thank you we will now move
oh sorry can't counsel a dale sorry
just to echo uh what council renek has
said there i
i i absolutely agree i think um i've
known clyde for
quite a few years he is a a lovely
chapman and he's very sad that he's been
unwell as far as i am concerned and the
information i have received is that
unfortunately his uh term of office
expired due to no attendance and that's
despite
um some dispensations that were uh
that were applied it wasn't possible to
apply a
retrospective retrospective dispensation
uh but i'm very happy to to discuss with
sarah and
other members and try and get to the
bottom of what what happened
but that's just my understanding as as
councilor renick says it's nothing to do
with me it's
it's a function of the monitoring
officer to to deal with these matters
but
happy to look into it thank you
thank you counselor lilly
thank you thank you chad i mean just
looking at the lines of what the
what the leaders just said uh and
looking for
a retrospective uh ruling on this
uh to to ask uh sarah uh in respect of
the law now it's
how it's stated i would imagine i mean
laws
come and go sometimes they work
sometimes they don't and they change
because of that
and i'm just wondering and this is in
this sort of instance
uh with the exceptional circumstances
particularly
with the nature of some of the illness
that that clive's been suffering
and the slowdown in treatment in those
areas
uh of course it does offer some really
exceptional circumstances
and i'm wondering if there is some
provision of appeal
uh with the law in respect of this so
that we can get to the bottom of this
and be fair
to any one of us who could come across
that same
problem at any time in our life not only
us
but members of our family particularly
in
in a a situation that we find ourselves
in now
with regards to covid
thank you councillor birkin thank you
chair
uh we seem to be missing the very
serious and valid point that i think
councillor hancock made
that there seems to be no recollection i
certainly don't as well as council
hancock so that's two of us
of the decision to extend councillor
hunt's
um absence by a further three months
when we had already
we had agreed and i remember that uh
coming to the council
but i don't think there was any instance
where we were asked to extend that by a
further amount be it three months or six
months um
i think as i said that's that's a very
valid point that council hancock's made
and we seem to be glossing over that can
we have some information as to
when uh the three months started and and
if it was brought to council
and if not which a couple of us seem to
remember then why it wasn't please thank
you chair
thank you
councillor whitehead yeah thank you
chair
um i just want to echo the the need for
an investigation um
if if an ex-councillor
was able to vote in a meeting that would
make them
a member of the public so i'd be
interested to know how
governance allowed that to happen
thank you sarah sarah sternberg
in relation to council lily's point
about retrospective actions because
that's essentially what he's asking for
it is quite specific in the legislation
that you have to do it before the end
the term of office of the member
so before the dispensation comes to an
end so no in practical terms we can't do
anything after the event
in terms of the question about this
being brought to members
we put it through a lot of emergency
well not a lot a number of emergency
powers
at the start of the first lockdown to
ensure that business could carry on
i'm not sure i haven't got it at my
fingertips or here but i believe that
one one of those delegations related to
the section 85 that would be part of
what i'd look at when i was talking to
councillors barker and dale
so i'd bring that to them
we will now move to the vote i will ask
the governance officer to issue the poll
sorry what we vote you on
that's the acceptance of the appointment
well we're at this point because of
because of the nature and i accept what
sarah said
i know this there's some sort of legal
challenges happening
at the time that that we're not
volunteering a name at this
this juncture
yes the report is about there being a
vacancy
and therefore the removal of one labour
member from the standards committee
in consequence it's not about putting
forward a name
it's about withdrawing somebody
well in that i mean at this juncture we
we we still think lives
got a chance of staying on so we're not
remove
we won't vote for that
councillor berkins indicating chair
councillor shipman
thank you chair um i just wondered if we
can actually get commitment from the
monitoring officer that an investigation
will have because i know everyone's
calling for one here but
i'm i'm getting the feeling that it's
going to be kicked into long grass as of
one minute past now and we're never
gonna hear about it again
can we actually get a commitment that
that will happen and then that a report
will be brought back to cancer so we
know
who made the decisions under what
delegated powers their decisions were
made
and what has been communicated to
councillor barca because if someone has
actually said
to councillor barker that um
councillor hunt's um dispensation was
ongoing still
and throwing it into a certain date and
that's a serious serious failure
and that needs to be addressed because
that's that that um has resulted in
taxpayers
wasting money here because we're gonna
have to have a by-election it's gonna
cost resources to put this on and
ultimately
someone in the governance team has
passed cancer well i'm
going on what council block has told me
has given him some information that he
deems is incorrect
and i think that that needs to be
addressed so can we actually get
confirmation that that will happen
we'll come back to council and we can
actually
look at this properly otherwise we're
not actually doing anything are we in
this whole debate's worth
thank you sarah sternberg i will be
looking at this and i will look through
all the details of what was sent to whom
and by whom and what decisions were made
and i will discuss that with councillors
barker and dale
but if you want a report back to council
i suggest you add it to the
recommendations
but i will be looking at it very
seriously it won't be forgotten
one minute after this meeting
and then can i move that we add that to
the recommendations of this report then
please chair
i would second nature
are the existing um mover and secondary
happy with that as an amendment
can we go to the vote then please now
speak on the amendment
uh sorry chair no it's it's a it's a
point of information
from i think what mr sternberg just said
the power of delegation for the
continuance or not of one of our fellow
councillors
was left to our officers is that right
absolutely one of the things i will
check but that was in the very early
days before virtual meetings were up and
running
um we did it in march i think that's the
case but that's what i would be checking
can you can you check who gave you those
power thing because i would have thought
that any council sitting here
would have been very very reluctant to
give away such or should have been
very very reluctant to give away such
powers no disrespect to you as an
officer
but because it puts you as an officer in
a very very very
difficult position as we are now finding
thank you chair
this was can i just say this was a very
difficult time when there were no
meetings and members
and we wanted to ensure there was a
safeguard for members on this particular
provision
so in the unusual circumstances we had
in march and april that was when it was
introduced
if it was there i have a fallible memory
i may be wrong
can i just say i'm sorry chair that's a
that's a fantastic safeguard that was
built in for officers and members there
can we vote now on the amendment
sorry chair just to be clear the
amendment then is to
retain the three recommendations which
are in the report
plus with um a final additional
recommendation
that there should be an investigation in
the matter of um
clive hunt and his membership of the
council
is that the essence of it yeah and the
decisions taken obviously
leading up to that point
thank you council armitage
uh i would have thought that uh
councillor dale to
uh used to come back uh as he
put the motion forward to start with uh
if he agrees with the amendment
yeah council dale yeah i mean in the
interest of speeding things up i'm happy
for the amendment
if that saves us having to vote on the
amendment and then the
uh the original motion i'm happy for the
investigation to be brought back to
council
um if cancer armitage is as well as the
second
yes i i agree with you the
yeah we're now vote
come on now vote on the sustainability
chair if i may help you you're being
asked to vote on the three
recommendations in the report plus the
additional one
that a report is an investigation done
and then report it back to council
i've i think we're going to do this by
poll
electronic poll just launch the poll now
it should be available for you to vote
children
hello can i speak sorry i'm a very
confused shouldn't we be voting just on
the amendment
and then if the amendment falls or gets
carried we can then vote on the original
yeah if if i might clarify the mover and
second of the main motion agreed to add
that so we're just going to vote on the
main motion
including that amendment
okay chair i've ended the polling and um
it's 39 votes for so that's been
carrying
sorry amy can i add two from the chamber
please yes of course sorry yes
so that's 41 votes for chair
sure there was a lot of confusion in
respect to that
and people like myself uh
and and council cornwall weren't really
actually sure what we were voting on or
agreeing still or whatever
i understood that uh under the situation
that would be voting for the amendment
voting on the amendment
uh and and that's the usual uh the usual
way things go the amendment
uh is moved and seconded and voted on if
it falls or whatever
then we proceed in this in the same
fashion
understanding orders either the
amendment is carried
and added to the motion if if they want
to make it as part of the motion
or it falls and we go back to the motion
so
i voted in a situation where i thought i
was voting for the amendment
now i found that i voted for something i
didn't want to vote for
so basically i think we ought to be
going through the exercise all over
again so that everybody
is aware and clear on what the position
is
chair i thought i when i spoke i made it
clear that you're voting on the main
motion the three recommendations in the
report
plus the agreed amendment which the
mover and second of the motion
main motion had agreed to add to the
recommendations
i did say that just before the vote
and that was my interpretation of what
the um motion was as well
the amendment was as well unfortunately
it certainly wasn't mine and i was asked
to ask to vote on it i wasn't clear
we have voted so we shall now move on
can i now invite councillor armitage to
present the report
the recruitment of a new independent
person
thank you chair you'll note from the
report
that one of our two independent persons
has indicated his wish to resign from
the position
and the council need to consider the
re-advertising of the post
standards committee have considered the
role of the independent
person previously and concur with the
proud
council's previous agreement to engage
two
ips to ensure continuity
in case of sickness or other
non-availability
this report therefore requests council
support
for the monitoring officer to commence a
recruitment
exercise for a replacement and to bring
forth
a suitable candidate for ratification
at a future council meeting
further the report suggests
that the stage of requesting recruitment
as it is being done here
is delegated in future to the monitoring
officer
we would of course ask for sarah to keep
group leaders and myself as general
standards
in form of a resignation and progress
towards a replacement
prior to an appointment report being
brought before the
council i would therefore
like to move recommendations
6.1 to 6.4
of the report
is our seconder i'm very happy to second
year
are there any comments
councillor hancock thank you chair
excuse me i'd just like to clarify with
councillor armitage if i could
um ask him to to reiterate the um
6.3 aspect
are we suggesting that the monitoring
officer makes the actual decision
of recruitment or are we still saying
that that would come back to council for
approval
i have concerns if it's if it's one but
not the other
i'll just refer to my notes counselor
if if i could help out most certainly
not coming to me for a decision
all this delegation does is allows me to
start the process so instead of coming
to the council twice
i can come once with the recruitment
process having been done
and having kept leaders of the parties
informed but suggesting a candidate for
appointment
so you can decide whether or not to
appoint
thank you sarah i'm in favor of it then
thank you
we'll now move to the vote i will ask
the governance
officer to
launch chair so it should be available
for those who
to 8.
and amy there's two four in the chamber
okay so that makes it 45 votes for so
that's carried chair
thank you i invite karen hanson director
of the environment
and enforcement could give a
presentation
thank you thank you chair um i'm just
going to attempt to scrap to share my
screen
hopefully this will work
okay amy can you confirm that you can
see that on the screen please
i can yes karen it's fine thank you very
much okay um good afternoon councillors
i'm just going to run through for you
our year one review and summary of the
achievements under the council plan for
2019-2023
you'll recall that the council plan
document looks like that one on the
screen
we agreed way back in september 2019
that we would divide the priorities up
into four
sections so our residents our
environment
our services and our economy
okay so the council plans a four-year
plan it's approved at full council on
the 9th
of september 2019 and we then commenced
a period of transition between the old
um council plan and the new one we
worked both of those together for the
final six months of that financial year
the formal performance monitoring of the
new plan came into effect from the first
of april
2020 and you'll recall that the first
lockdown the first wave of
covid 19 commenced in march 2020 so to
date
the uh council plan has been impacted
severely by the uh
the coronavirus and kobit 19 um
uh amendments that we've put forward and
i'll explain that as i go forward
in the presentation wanted to start off
by
going through some achievements this is
by uh by no means all achievements
um so far it's a snapshot of the key
headlines really
um there's quite a lot in terms of
bullet points so i will ensure that you
get a copy
of the presentation with the minutes of
the meeting in case you want to look at
any further details
after the presentation itself okay so in
terms of the first section
our residence we have already
uh finished quite a lot of these that
these targets and these priorities so
the council tax was frozen
as agreed in the manifesto and was put
forward in the council plan
the older people's strategy was approved
by a council for 2020
2023 and that sets out the council's
vision to support older people
within the uh district through work
health
safety social isolation leisure and also
financial inclusion in addition we've
continued our commitment to the armed
forces covenant and we've
built on the bronze award that we were
initially awarded with and we're now
on the silver award which acknowledges
exceptional support to the armed forces
community
there's a lot more information about
that if anybody wants anything then
please let me know and we can go through
exactly
and what we've achieved in terms of that
award so far
we've also signed up to all five pledges
of the british deaf association's
charter
british sign language and to date again
many actions have already been carried
out um even though we've been through
a lengthy period of covered response um
all service managers have been briefed
on the requirements
and we're well on our way to making some
major improvements there in terms of
accessibility
the new council website has been
launched and i hope you'll agree with me
that it
is improved from the last one uh it
looks very good and we had a lot of
a lot of hits on that website so far and
that was a
launched ahead of its target date and
um it contains more accessibility
features and documents than ever before
so that's another big piece of work that
we've managed to achieve
we also working with the county council
have a comprehensive offer for children
in care and care leavers
and that that includes things like the
council tax discount
scheme leisure membership and other
initiatives that we've worked with the
county council on and then finally on
that page
for residents we've also adopted the
single equality scheme for 2019-2023
and that's our commitment to providing
services which promote equality and
fairness
and also challenge inequality and
discrimination
if i can move on to the environment um
a huge piece of work that the council
has as a major priority and a big
commitment to
is around the climate change strategy
and you'll be aware that we've approved
the climate change strategy and declared
the climate
change emergency and you'll see listed
on that slide
um five or six bullet points which just
underpins some of the work that's
already
taken place um councillor dale mentioned
earlier the three million pounds green
homes program
uh which also contains 575 000 pounds
worth of funding
towards that program to upgrade council
properties
we've issued the climate exchange advice
pack to parish councils which i think
has been received very well
um and they've offered thanks for that
and and they're using it regularly with
uh
with their parishes we've got the
thousand pounds low carbon skills fund
um the led lighting upgrades
um leisure facility upgrades as well
where are underway and
i'm working closely within our ledger
teams to make sure that those are
carried through
with the covid 19 arrangements working
from home and agile working
really was thrown upon us overnight and
we've um
started to really look at that in detail
to make sure that we can still
um work towards the priorities of the
council while ensuring that we have a
very agile and flexible workforce
working safely within covid arrangements
and that
has worked very well so far and we also
have the
wild planting policy for parks and open
spaces
approved as a result of that we have
carbon emissions
reduction across the district and we
also
work with and and potentially lead on
the county-wide
climate group if anybody wants any more
information about that
there is also um at the meeting this
afternoon we'll be able to give you some
more information about that piece of
work it's very big and
very comprehensive okay
in terms of our services section of the
council plan
again we've got some more strategic
pieces of work completed including the
digital strategy
probably as a result of covid but
nonetheless a very very good
piece of work is around the increase of
online service transactions in 2019 and
2020 and that's
continued to increase um due to kobe
dinner and
also our communication strategy around
getting as many people
to transact with us online as possible
um
and as appropriately as possible we're
investing in our own staff as well
through a range of
um ideas and initiatives and one of
those is the leadership program
and i know that that's been very very
well attended and that the staff
involved in that
are really progressing very well in
terms of growing our own skills
for the future leadership of the council
we've also undertaken recently some
management restructure and you'll be
aware of that in terms of the
higher levels of management across the
council to make sure
that we have the right people in place
to fit the new priorities and ambition
of the council working forward and i
mentioned earlier piece of work we've
done around climate change with the
parish councils but
that goes further than that and we also
have enhanced working arrangements with
them
uh it's worked very well throughout the
covid pandemic we
have kept in regular contact with parish
councils and town councils
to share information and provide advice
guidance and support where it's been
required
just going uh into a little bit more
detail around that
we've worked very hard with the
community support team to support over 7
000 residents with specific inquiries um
as part of the copic pandemic making
food parcels deliveries
and also almost 10 000 pharmacy
deliveries
during the first wave of covert 19. that
work hasn't stopped
i want to give you reassurance that work
is ongoing the clovid support
team the community support team are
still up and running
um the call center is still making those
calls to the most vulnerable residents
but what we have found nationally as
well as as locally
is that people are much more prepared
for the second wave they have um
more access routes to gain food supplies
working with big supermarkets um and
other voluntary sector
arrangements to make sure that all of
that is in place and there's nowhere
near
the same requirement and the same need
for um
the kind of emergency support that we
saw in the first wave which is
which is very good to hear we've also
jointly reviewed some of the ricknail
homes arrangements to fit the new
priorities and the ambitions of the
council
and that includes policies as well so
not only the structure of written
homes and the monitoring arrangements
and the management agreement but also
policies and i've just given you a
couple of examples there so the
joint domestic abuse policy and also the
community safety work that we do jointly
with
with uh written homes particularly
around antisocial behavior
okay moving on to our economy um again
some very large pieces of work strategic
pieces of work
that are taking place in the continuing
uh throughout
the pandemic have been the clay
crosstown board which has formed uh the
specialists who appointed in the town
investment plan has been submitted
um and i think jill uh calling them may
well be discussing that and talking
through those arrangements with you
um in a moment as part of the agenda of
this meeting
there's also three job spares that have
taken place
uh two virtually the first one was prior
to uh
the pandemic arrangements but uh the
second
and third were virtual and we're still
very very
well attended we've used a lot of social
media platforms
we've promoted the arrangements with a
large number of businesses
and we've had some really good
engagement and interaction
and a huge take-up which has been really
pleasing actually for everybody in our
economic development team
and the next fair is planned to take
place um in the new year
around 27th of january
okay um you'll be aware that there was a
requirement very very early on and
throughout
the pandemic uh to do a lot of work to
support businesses wherever we possibly
could
including the very quick and efficient
distribution of government support
grants so i've listed there just four
types of grants that we've already been
involved in so we've got the local
authority discretionary grants fund
the 18 million pounds worth of business
grants awarded
uh through a range of different grant
systems
and then um as the second wave of the
pandemic
we now have a further three grant
funding schemes to assist businesses
which we're working on as we speak and i
know that
many offices are working very very hard
and very quickly to try and get those
guidance notes and
that money out to businesses and also
the test and trace isolation payments um
are being managed by our revenues and
benefits department
okay so um in addition to that and i
guess this crosses over with the
services section as well but we've also
carried out some thorough and
fundamental reviews of the planning team
and the environmental health services
team to ensure that they're both fit for
purpose and that they can
continue to offer excellent services and
be effective
and well resourced and with a skilled
workforce
we've taken our time in doing that
because we wanted to make sure that they
were very
very rigorous service reviews we've
managed to
i think councilor dale referred to it
right at the very beginning during his
announcements
but we've managed to secure some growth
in both of those teams to make sure that
we have
focus on the right things so we've got
some arbor cultural and heritage
resource going into the planning team
along with some
robust enforcement officers and
environmental health it really is around
making sure we've got the right
professionals in the right place and
that we're
able to recruit and retain staff
um effectively on on our patch and to
also grow our own skills and to keep
those jobs within our district wherever
possible
as a result of the pandemic we've also
now set up a specific
covid support team in environmental
health and that
um team albeit quite small at the moment
but it's working very very closely on a
daily basis with the public health unit
at the county council to ensure that we
do as much as we possibly can
around infection control to make sure
that businesses have everything in place
that they need
around support advice and guidance to
ensure that they can continue to trade
when the uh
lockdown is lifted um in a covered
secure way
working very very closely around
any clusters that arise or any outbreaks
have copied within business arrangements
in the district
um and again i think just the last two
bullet points there
are around the um improvements to the
planning team so we've got the planning
enforcement plan which has now been
improved
and we're also exceeding targets for
processing major and my
minor planning applications
okay so the first year review has taken
place and what we've done is we've
looked at all of our existing
performance targets for the very first
12 months
of the plan period we've ensured that
they're still relevant and you'll
probably
be aware that um covid19 really has
affected the council plan across all
areas really especially around economic
development and the refocus
around the support required for
businesses has been quite extensive
all heads of service have consulted with
their respective cabinet members
and we've done some housekeeping as well
so we've looked at some of the key
performance indicators which should
really be in service
plans and remove them and push them down
a little bit and also brought out some
new ones which are more
effective for what we need now
okay so in terms of some new targets and
there's kinds of things that we're going
to be looking at moving forward and i
mentioned earlier about the effects of
of the pandemic it really is around
support for businesses
um through effective signposting
establishing some apprenticeship support
we're going to be launching any day now
an apprenticeship hour for businesses to
call us for advice and support around
setting up apprenticeships and
and driving forward that training and
apprenticeship program
we're looking at implementing and
managing an annual program of capital
improvements and monitoring performance
against the corporate equality
objectives which i mentioned earlier so
there's quite a lot
there in terms of refining what we're
already doing
the next slide really just builds on
that particularly around the production
of the growth
strategy tourism strategy and an
employment and skills
strategy all of those have
really taken on a completely different
life of their own
following the pandemic they we've gone
from a response mode to a recovery mode
and back into a response mode for the
second wave
of the pandemic so the work that we're
doing around growth and employment and
tourism
has completely changed focus and that's
why we'll be delivering those new
strategies
by the very beginning of next year
there's a continuation and progression
of the business cases around opi the one
public estate
program programme for eckington and
killer marsh and
also the clay cross investment plan
um i think quite an exciting piece of
work which has just started is around
the development of a master plan for
dronfield civic center
and we'll also continue to drive forward
those jobs fairs which have been so
um well attended and appear to be so
important across
the district in terms of work in
progress
uh we'll continue to support residents
to upskill um to improve
employability through the initiatives
there of that bullet point around job
space and kickstart particularly around
construction
in the district and we're going to look
at an asset management strategy to
maximize
income and also some more of those
enforcement activities when the time
feels right and is appropriate to do so
um
every piece of enforcement that we do
now we really do consider the
appropriateness of it whether it be
fixed penalty notices
whether it be around um joined up
enforcement between planning and
environmental health
so we understand that we need to
continue with enforcement appropriately
but we don't want to be overzealous
taking into account
uh the situation of businesses at the
moment um so we are really thinking that
through and making sure that it's a
joined up but also very effective and
where it needs to be
okay and i think my final slide really
just confirms what i've just said
so in terms of the impact of covid on
the council plan itself we've had to
really go into business continuity
arrangements uh since
march we are delivering all priority
services and also a lot of non-priority
services now
but we have had to really rethink some
of the ways that we go about doing that
a lot of it's online a lot of it has
changed in terms of how we engage with
people
and what expectations are both of the
council
and our expectations of businesses and
residents across the whole of the
district
um we've put in place an extensive
package of community support
particularly around the first
wave using um staff who weren't able to
do their normal day job and moving them
on to supporting the public
to make sure that they have exactly what
they need
particularly around food parcels and
pharmacy deliveries and
mental health support as well
response and recovery plans have really
uh taken off we've got comprehensive
plans both internally and externally to
recover
from the first wave and we're also now
actively responding
to the second wave of coverage
particularly in the lockdown period as
we are now
and finally kind of business support and
environmental health
infection control and enforcement a lot
of our resources have been refocused
from what they were doing and
re-prioritized to make sure
that we have all of that in place as a
priority some of the other
pieces of work that we wanted to move
forward um are currently on
ice while we make sure that we have
those really key
pieces of work on that key support
ongoing but there's not an awful lot
really that hasn't
uh been looked at that we said we would
look at um we just need to make sure
that we get our priorities
in the right place when we're working
through the pandemic
and i think that's it from me if
anybody's got any questions myself lee
and jill will be able to answer anything
that you may have i'll just stop sharing
this now
thank you
[Music]
are there any questions counselor
ridgeway
yeah can just a bit of clarity um you
said the test and trace payment
can you tell me what that is is that is
that paying staff
that are um are you paying them full
pay if they test um positive for covered
19.
no that's a that's a payment a national
payment we administer so if anybody
across the district
has to self-isolate um and they qualify
there is a qualification they can
claim a payment of 500 pounds to support
them and their families whilst they're
in self-isolation so if they have if
they suffer detriment and they
need to benefit then they can claim a
500 pounds payment
right so so you're saying that's for
businesses some
no no right okay so that's for residents
so
so are residents aware of that because
all i'm my concern is that if somebody
is working um and they test positive
and they have to take time off which
they would do
they can't afford the rent
and that goes against them are they
going to be told that there is that
payment for them to be able to
pay that two weeks rent because this is
what's going to happen people are going
to be worried
um about evictions and things like that
so i think there needs to be a little
bit more clarity on that
um and i think the general public need
to know that that money's there
if it is needed okay thank you
to apply because you'll be aware of how
many of those
tests and trace of um applications we've
received and how we're going about
communicating that jane are you around
i'm karen yes thank you
thank you councillor ridgeway yes the
rebs and ben's team are administering
this but it is a national scheme and
it's been
publicized nationally we have got links
to our website but i will of course
check that that's prominent enough
because you're absolutely right it's a
really valuable scheme for the people
that want
to use it we are getting an awful lot of
claims i think we've had 52 so far
um so we are processing quite a lot of
claims across the district
um we are doing it in conjunction with
the national test and trace system
and we're getting the payments out as
quickly as we can and the people that
are receiving it you're right i'm very
grateful for it
yeah i appreciate that but i think um
not everybody has access to
um the web especially if they're very
sort of
no disrespect people that you know maybe
cannot afford um
to have the web so i think it needs to
be clarified in
maybe on their rent um book or something
do you know me i just think there needs
to be other ways that we
we can you know let people know about
this because obviously people want to
work
they don't want to go off but if they
haven't got access to
the internet because they can't afford
it because some people can't afford it
um how are you going about letting those
people know
that you know there is that money there
to to help bridge that gap
if if they do need it
happy to take that away councillor
ridgeway and have a look at the other
mediums that we can use for it so
that's lovely thank you
councillor barker
you check yeah yeah i mean that's a
obviously a very positive report karen
and
and well presented and and uh
everything's okidori and i suppose
as the lead opposition i should pull it
to pieces but i'm not going to
i'll probably get a tool in my group for
uh for not doing that
but i think we are in a position where
we're working
uh you know with this culvert crisis and
and we do really want to
to sort of work together and i think
alex you know by
reinventing the viper meetings and
things like that it does feel as though
we are in uh unprecedented times and and
while ever we
be uh providing the services
that we are like you said at the
beginning both at the council and at
wrigley i think we're doing a great job
i think one thing that was missing out
to that was
the the money because i'm i'm reading
not just here obviously at northeast but
the majority councils when the dust
settles
it is going to impact on services and
and while it might look good at the
moment
i think we have got to start making and
i'm sure you're thinking about this that
when we come out of this
uh whether we can actually carry on
maintaining all those services or
whatever reason and while ever it looks
great
this year i think that the the there are
issues coming forward
and i know we mentioned him at viper and
alex mentioned him in his
in his uh reports but uh let's not
lose sight of that that it's going to be
very difficult indeed i think
thank you anyway thank you councillor
for now
i am here i'm trying to get a thing off
the screen can you hear me okay
see me i can i can hear you
is that better yes
yeah yeah thanks for that karen you must
be exhausted dealing with all that sort
of
activity just one area that i wanted to
focus on
one line you talked about an asset
management strategy
and that was going to maximize income i
wonder if you could elaborate on that a
little bit more
the asset management strategy
okay i may need to pull jill in for this
um as part of the asset management
program
but it's all really around making sure
that the council uses its assets to the
best advantage
particularly around the business
premises that the council owns um but
jill have you got any further things to
add around that
sorry about that i was just struggling
to uh unmute myself
so um the the idea is we own uh
areas of land we've got some we've got
regeneration plans around clay cross
and drum field and eckington and killer
marsh
and the idea is that we have a
comprehensive plan about understanding
how we're going to use
our landfill regeneration purposes or
maximizing income
because we own some assets as well and
are we making the best use of them
particularly coming out of covid
and where business needs support so it's
kind of looking at that again
in a post-covered world to what's best
to serve northeast derbyshire
okay does that mean disposal and selling
of land
and property there there's potential to
do that
to develop it to join it with other
pieces of land
um that's it just needs to be looked at
to see are we
are we doing the best we can so it's in
its early stages at the moment then yeah
okay thank you thank you
council councillor birkin
thank you chair uh very detailed
presentation karen thank you very much
for that
is it possible to get um copies of your
presentation so we can uh
look at it maybe more closely uh uh with
a bit more time
that we've got ourselves thank you yes
definitely it was definitely a
whistle-stop
tour so i'll send it out to you and then
if you want to pick up any of the points
um and send me through any questions
then i will get some comprehensive
responses back to you with a bit more
detail if you need it thank you thanks
very much
councillor renwick
thank you in response to cancer ridgeway
um
i was was hoping that um macbeth is an
update from ricknald in terms of
the support they're giving to people uh
renting
and also to ask if jane delic could
share
i think when she's got all the full
information from the grants
um i know there's been a lot of work
done on that and i've had a fact sheet
and that might be useful to be
circulated to all members in case
you get queries and some of these things
um
but i'd just like to say thank you to
karen and
huge thank you to officers and staff for
their
tremendous achievement um and their
standing work and stepping up at this
difficult time
and for achieving a great many of the
objectives originally set plus
additional ones that obviously we hadn't
anticipated
i wanted to also give a shout out to the
economic development team
revenue and benefits environmental
health and the partnership team
for all the advice support guidance and
the timely manner in which they um
distributed the gap the grants to
thousands of businesses
over this crisis and i know you're
working hard to to work with the next
lots of brands um obviously these
weren't targets that we
put in but we were certainly smashed
them in terms of uh our
numbers of business spoken to over this
last few few months
and just to say that i'd have had dozens
of messages
from businesses thanking our staff for
their support
and i'd just like that to be noted for
the record thank you
thank you we will now move to a vote to
note their
presentation okay
i think councillor powell's indicating
that he wishes to speak oh
sorry council powell oh yeah i'd just
like to echo what's uh cancer running
i have um i have a number of uh
friends who are in business in sheffield
and they keep saying they wish they
lived in north east derbyshire because
we get the grants out a lot quicker than
anybody else
um i'd i'd just like to echo the thanks
really to the officers
um when karen says there are large
pieces of work
she's being very modest they are very
large pieces of work
um and to have to do that against the
background of the pandemic
has been truly remarkable so i'd just
like to say
thanks for all the work you're doing
thank you
counselor dale sorry just just to echo
uh the thanks to offers there and uh
thanks to
officers there and just in response to
councillor barker's
uh point there was a lot of uh
achievements there
uh but i think it's important that uh to
note that we're not complacent in any
way there's actually several areas of
the council plan that has
understandably been affected by covid
we're having to adapt we're having to
change or having to do do new things so
uh it's
you're right it's not always all rosy
and there is balance there and uh
but i do think as i said at the
beginning it's important that we do
um we don't let covid
um disrupt you know the progress that we
want to make as a council
and some of the priorities that we all
have as as as members of the council so
thanks once again to the officers for
all of their work as well as cabinet
members
and also councillor backer obviously as
uh as leader for uh for a lot of the
uh you know the time that those those
achievements have been made thank you
we will now move to a vote to note the
presentation come over show of hands
please
that appears to be unanimous sure yes
thank you
carried
i'm i invite jill cullingham
director of growth and economic
development to give a presentation
uh thank you chair um does somebody want
to give me oh
got access now thank you
i'm gonna just check alan you can see
that uh yes yes it's visible
okay
you that's it yeah yeah so uh thank you
i'm
i'm gonna um just quickly bring you up
to date with what's happening
um in clay cross as part of the towns
fund
um for those that um
maybe a little while since you you've
looked at this
um the government announced a town's uh
fund
back in september 2019
pre-covered if you can remember those
times
and it was around supporting
towns within um england
that have suffered economic decline
uh neither they need a boost and it was
looking
at 3.6 billion pounds to be shared
amongst those
north east derby show put in a bid for
clay cross
and was successful and since that time
we have been looking to create a town
investment
plan there's a two
stage approach to the deal and we have
been working our way
through stage one which was to create a
board
because the the towns deal isn't
a council run thing it is a clay cross
independent board
um but we are here to support it
um and through that we need you to
create an investment plan
about how we would use the 25 million
pounds within
the clay cross to support economic
development and various other areas of
health well-being um the second stage
which we're about to move into is
turning that investment plan into
business cases and start delivering on
the ground
the government gave us some funding to
early on to appoint
consultants to help us with that process
and earlier in the year we
got nexus as our consultant
the town the town board is really
important part of this and it's really
important
that it's got private sector
involvement in it and that it represents
the communities it serves so
from that you can see that we it is
chaired by
uh gary golden from worcester bosch one
of the major employers
in clay cross and includes a range of
providers that provides sports support
parish councils in there sports england
homes england
um and um skills is really important as
part of this
this work so chesterfield college are a
part there
as well um
the main the first part of the clay
cross plan was to understand what it is
we're trying to do in clay cross what
needs to happen to make it um that
really special place
to live it's had years of decline when
when the
coal mining industry stopped um but it's
growing in the fact there's a housing
development around that area new people
are coming into the area
and to make it a really successful town
particularly after covid19
what is it we need to put into place to
make it give it a nice rounded
town feel um plans were drawn up and
there were two
stages of consultation um june july
this year during coving 19
did issues and opportunities within clay
cross
and that went out to people within clay
cross and the wider area
and then the outcome of that was
developed into a draft investment plan
and that went out again for consultation
in july and august
um when that information came back that
was considered and that became the basis
of the investment plan
which we we've submitted now to
government
government released 500 000 pounds as
accelerator fund to get
you started on your journey
through the investment plan and we've
identified projects
around um
demolishing uh buildings to make way for
development
and to get an art project started
um and a few few other things so we've
identified what we want to
do with that or the board has identified
and endorsed one that when he needs to
be used for
um this is the plan um
in draft so this is just looking at it
very high level terms you can find this
on the council's website if you look
but if you google towns fund you you'll
find it there so just give
you a little bit of background that's
this area here
that's tesco and this here is
charlie park leisure center so part of
one of the schemes is to
renew that and to make it into a
well-being hub
um there are um
projects to change the infrastructure so
it's better walking and cycling routes
and
and through clay cross creating
more of a town centre that's missing
because we've got a lot of car parking
possibly not in the right areas
um and then creating kind of a skills
somewhere that's
that skills could um be be used where
people can learn new skills
and making um outreach areas
and to support businesses in in clay
cross
so we ended up with 10 projects uh and
these are the ones that we've submitted
as part of our investment plan and i'll
just quickly improve
so market streets looking at creating a
market square some commercial homes
bridge street relocating the bus state
descent station supporting housing
uh leisure commercial premises clay
cross creative
there is um that that's
around how we use community assets
there's um and how we can
support people in that wider creative
areas that it's a bit lacking at the
moment in clay cross
talked about charlie park we've got a
skills hub
an enterprise hub again that'll be
working with
fe providers and the universities
play across connections it's about that
public realm
and transport links low carbon
workspace there's a theme for clay cross
and of low energy
clean carbon and making things more
energy efficient
and so we're looking at creating more
business space but
with a low carbon focus the building
will be low carbon
again low carbon housing in clay cross
might be linked to charlie park some
district heating type thing
which leads into that energy network
that we're looking at and the last thing
we're looking at is a train
feasibility study for clay cross that
will look
it won't be delivered in the time of the
plan which is the next five years but it
will start that process about looking to
clay cross to get a train station so
that's one of the other projects we put
forward
government um the current position is
that we've
submitted that plan it was signed off by
the board and it was submitted at the
end of october
um as a board we've had a number of
private sector
um members but with coving 19 some of
those had to drop off because they've
got
business commitments and so we're going
through a drive at the moment to get
more
private sector bodies on that that board
within the board there are working
groups to work on each of those projects
and those
some of those are well ahead like
charlie park and other ones have just
been
established what's really clear to us
that we need to
engage with younger people in um clay
cross so we're looking to create a youth
board
that can then feed into their to their
main cross board um
the submission to government uh we're
going through a stage now where we have
to
answer their queries they are assessing
our bids
and it takes about if anything from
what's happened
on the wave one bids is um takes about
four months so we're expecting to hear
back around february and march
the bids that have been announced so far
that went in at june i've been in the 20
million up to 25 million so they've been
in the early 20s 21 22 23
have been given to those towns so we're
hopeful if that carries on we should be
around that level
and i think that is my end of my
presentation and i'm happy to take any
questions
just stop sharing
council barker
just to comment really and and i mean
i've been in involved with this from
start and i think again
the way that that car lapses has pulled
in to sort of pull it all together
and uh and trying to get this bid in
because it's
it's the time scale's been a bit short
and he and
i think this is only the first title
because the uh getting the bidding
uh and and then obviously when the money
comes then
we've got to then then it gets the way
it starts if you like but this process i
think the officers
involved have done really well i just
made the comment and it
has been made to me that there are quite
a lot of of local
people that feel left out of this
process
that have got skills and and things so
if we can involve uh some of the
community groups a bit more but that
that's something going forward because
there are i know i can name two or three
that
that live and breathe clear cross you
know what to me than that they know it
from inside out not just and all the
businesses have got to be involved to
tick the boxes but
i think we've got to take the community
with us as well and i'm not quite
getting that buying at the moment i'm
feeling that's
that's what i'm feeling jill and it's
something we need to consider going
forward
but but to get the bid in in the time
scale has been fantastic
and if we can get 20 million 24 million
for clay cross then
brilliant thank you councillor i'll make
sure that we uh
we liaison work out which of those
groups that want to be involved in the
working groups they're setting up thank
you
thank you councillor wendla
thank you chair and hi jill and could i
ask
about i haven't got the map now in front
of me the
you know um the market square you talk
about
in in market street area where
where is that planned in for please
want me to share that plan again so this
is quite high level so
yes thank you so let me bring it up for
you
everybody's seen that now
i'm going to take that easy yes so um
the market square
is around this area here can you say
with
um 10 2 and 13 are written where it says
cinema
so this red area here is where the
market's going so we've got a a
residential
and potentially a market there
and this at the back here that area
there that's where the tesco
petrol station is right so
you're dropping it lower down from
market street that is
am i looking at that right
yeah so tesco's here tesco big stores
here
yeah tesco um
petrol stations there right and then
this is the roundabout so it's on that
roundabout on that roundabout yeah yeah
so you know that area that doesn't
really yeah lots of
bits of um businesses in it's about
making a place
there and then that is about joining
that
to the rest of uh this area here which
is
got car parking in right and joining
then
some routes up um to join it to to the
rest of
um major points in in
clay cross yeah yeah so it's still
actually
moving things away from the original old
market street where these businesses
that's always
been there and i know they've they've
been struggling
since we had tesco's and because it's
sort of moved doesn't it now the town
centre
so i just wondered if you've got any
plans to sort of
you know bring that back in for those
businesses that are there
so i'm going to bring carl in on on this
because he'll be able to go into more
detail but
at the moment for me it feels like
everything's a bit tesco dominated over
here
and you've got the small indep you know
the independence so by moving a market
square here you've kind of bringing
those independent
more towards those independent uh stores
to make a a town centre and away from
tesco being dominating so you know
you've you've got
space to do it there right
is there any sorry carl do you want to
add anything in
yeah the the town investment plan is
very much about putting their footfall
back into the town centre and making
sure that people have a reason to attend
and to sort of try and support those
businesses that are existing
so a lot of workers around creating a
heart again within the town
center and it recognizes um it's a
market time without a market
so that was kind of a big part of the
workers identifying
the correct and appropriate space for
that and then looking to see how we can
sort of bring that forward so that's a
big part of the attack lesson plan is
is making it a market town again and
trying to make it more of a
functional space because as you rightly
say tesco
dominates um play across and it almost
becomes a town
so divided by the road network that
means that most people drive into
tesco's
do their shopping there and don't
necessarily do a second trip
into the to see the independent
retailers that are on them
the rest of clay cross so that's a big
part of that work is how do we integrate
tesco's within the rest of play cross
and and amends that
sever between the two and uh increase
the footfall on to the independent
retailers
right still moving it a little bit away
from the market street as it is though
isn't it
well the area is actually a bit um
to the it's not quite where where jill
had mentioned it's a bit further down
and to the right and it's a bit nearer
where the job center
currently is so it's around that space
you know where the large
um um junction and all the rest is it's
actually
near that part which feels more the
heart of the town
potentially so it's a little bit to the
to the right of where
has been indicated then so yeah it's
it's bringing that foot forward we think
it's that the right
the right place and it's about
relocating so the bus station actually
relocates to the other part
which then opens that space up and makes
it a lot more usable and like i said
then it's a better connection between
tesco's and the independent retailers
and it's almost like a natural pool
to pull people into that and to those
independent retailers as you say because
they're the ones we
need to support yeah yeah so it's not as
i was thinking
the other the other place where jill
said it's quite a walk
actually you know not everybody can walk
that far but that
that is is a better plan isn't it yeah
thank you
thank you very cancel that was my fault
because at this arrow's here and i'm
doing
two begin areas so the arrow for this
comes down and drops
right in the middle there and yeah
that's fine that's fine jill thank
thank you councillor reno
yeah thanks thank you so much jill um
and
i sit on the board and uh this is a
hugely exciting project
for clay cross and it's a it really is a
once in generation opportunity to
transform
the authority of clay cross for its
residents businesses and the
wider area and community and um
hopefully with part of stage two um
council windley will hopefully see a bit
more detail
as the business plans work so but i i
just hope that um
everyone little council will agree and
fully endorse the work of the town board
uh and wish them well in the next stages
and i also like particularly thank
carl apps who's been leading uh officer
on this project
it has been quite a sprint to get over
the first line
and uh i think uh council black was
right to point out that
obviously the the the big campaign we
had in terms of uh
uh initially to try and get more
responses you know join covert was
more difficult and um there's definitely
opportunities to
get more input at the next stage so i'd
like to also thank uh
council molly and council barker for
their important support
and the parish council to help shape
this bid and
now the hard work really starts and
there's definitely opportunity for
anybody who wants to get involved and to
make suggestions
and to see the plans develop here's your
opportunity now and we
will double our efforts getting more
people involved in the working group to
the next stage
thank you everybody
thank you are there any more comments
we will now move to our vote to note the
presentation
a show of hands please
that appears to be unanimous chair yes
can i now invite councillor parking to
present the report
pleasure and management update thank you
thank you chair
um yes uh this report provides an update
on the council's
treasury management activities for april
2020 to september 2020.
one details uh the current borrowing
activity
and interest paid on external borrowing
as well as
providing an update on the council's
investments
and interest these generate we were
initially concerned as i have no doubt
every councillor
uh here would uh would know would concur
um about uh about the coveted pandemic
and
how how that would impact the way
that uh the council's finances were
managed i've got to say that uh
our cash flow position in particular was
was the first one of concern
early action was taken and and in actual
fact it remained
relatively static throughout and this is
a
largely as a result of the measures that
were put in place in that early
in the early phases under the leadership
of uh
council martin thacker at the time and
um
and i have to say that uh the period of
time between
the imposition of of the change and uh
and later in the year uh put a
a big load on the finance department
because we were having to
literally uh approve every single
purchase which was
right uh but it did put an exceptional
load on there so i'd like to thank uh
in particular the finance team for that
period of
uh of work and everything they do of
course
and so uh as a result of that the
um the cash flow has been relatively
static as i say throughout this year so
far
certainly throughout the period of this
report and
so the measures that were put in place
plus uh the receipt of government grants
and reimbursements
which have assisted us financially and
and it's important to note here that the
government made
the government making a decision to pay
these
grants up front rather than their normal
practice of paying them on a monthly
basis
uh has meant uh the the cash flow
position
of the council has been able to be
sustained over
over the coming period over the period
that we have the first uh
block down and beyond um
there were some comments earlier in in
the council meeting about uh
about about the coming year uh and we'll
have more on that very soon
but uh councillor barker's observations
i believe it was
uh are are absolutely correct we we uh
we are involved in uh attempting to
forecast the
unforecastable uh so
i hope you'll appreciate it when we do
have the budget meeting in february
uh that uh those things are a moving
feast even now
even today so the government paid all
the s31 grants up front
rather than the normal monthly uh and
that did help
and uh the deferment of business rates
payments for the first six months of
course
uh as well collection rates for council
tax
uh and rents um down
point seven four percent and one point
four percent uh respectively
uh they're down on previously years but
clearly not significantly
uh which has also helped so uh the good
people of uh northeast derbyshire
have kept us afloat thank you um as
you'd expect the biggest drop is for
business rates which is 6.5
down on previous years um and
as a result of this i'd like to move the
recommendation at 6.1
for the council note the treasury money
treasury management activities
undertaken during the period
april to september 2020 as outlined
in appendix one
thank you is there a seconder
i'm happy to second chair thank you
are there any comments
no one appears to be indicating sure
sorry i will ask the governance officer
to issue a poll
thank you
paul's been issued chair to be available
for those who have access to it to paint
plus amy plus 2 in the chamber
okay if those are four then that's
unanimous everyone's voted for the
recommended action
item 12 vision derbyshire has been
withdrawn so we shall move on to
um answer any questions from the
procedure rule number two no
14 i can confirm that we did receive one
question
submitted under procurement rule 9.2
but it was with agreement withdrawn
prior to the meeting
so we shall move to the next item
in accordance with council procedure
rule 10 i can confirm that we have two
motions to consider
i now invite councillor shipman to move
motion a
on the agenda thank you chair i just
wondered whether with your permission
it would be okay if councillor dale
could update us on where the counties
are and
because i know we've obviously since the
motion's gone in uh
the government's changed its mind on
funding um
sending funding to the county council
and obviously we've had me
we've had discussions at viper and some
things are going forward
i just wanted to whether it would be
prudent for councillor they'll just
update the
council is where we're at because if
things are in place which is to the um
which is along the lines of this motion
then i might as well just pull it if
we're already moving towards that
step if that's okay chair and if council
dale's happy to do that but
i think it might be useful for all
members to understand what's going on
can we move for a second on the motion
counselor dale are you able to speak
yeah
i'm very happy to i was actually um
assuming that the motion was
um wasn't withdrawn i was going to
suggest an amendment anyway almost to
bring it
um up to up to date so i think um
council shipment will appreciate
as he says it's things have moved on
since the day that he submitted the
motion
so um i mean just by way of a of a
quick update um for the members and i
have been
trying to provide updates at viper
meetings um the government has now
announced the kovid winter grant scheme
uh
totaling 170 million pounds uh and
derbyshire's allocation
is 2.18 million pounds uh now that the
money is ring fenced 80
to food and bills to support vulnerable
uh children and their families
and just to put that into context we
calculate that in one week of free
school meal vouchers should we
should we be purchasing those in
derbyshire would cost about 350
000. so the grant of 2.8 2.18 million is
is quite substantial it's um it is
supposed to last us until march 2021 so
in reality if you're focusing on the
holiday periods it's supposed to cover
us for
two weeks of holiday in christmas plus
one week in february
on top of that the government has
announced the extension of the holiday
activities and food programme
to december 2021 totaling uh
220 million uh pounds as well as a range
of other measures
now work is already underway at the
county council to work out
uh eligibility criteria uh and
and the scope of what sort of support we
can we can offer
um it's fair to say that the guidance uh
from the government hasn't yet
uh been released uh they're referring to
hoping to do that a bit a bit later this
month which makes planning
for delivery a little bit challenging as
you can imagine however
officers from the county council have
attended a um
a a briefing with um
with colleagues from the mhclg to
explain
a little bit more and it's clear that
although there are
some expectations in terms of reporting
back to government
on what has been delivered the things
like the eligibility criteria
are are quite flexible so it's up to the
county
working with partners and other
stakeholders to determine
who they want to provide support to it
doesn't have to just be
three school meals
[Music]
sort of recipients it doesn't rigidly
have to stick to that list
it could go wider um it could also go to
vulnerable older people for example who
are on their own
um so there is quite a lot of work still
underway at the county council
um to try and establish options of what
exactly we could fund with the money
what what sort of groups of
people or different criterias of
eligibility we could
approach i'm very happy to keep the
viper meetings updated on on how that
progresses
it may well be that some form of
vouchers is required because of
logistics and the
capacity uh issues within the sort of
voluntary sector at the moment
we know that the voluntary sector is
having to focus quite a lot on
uh the uh the uh clinically extremely
vulnerable
uh group um so in terms of christmas and
the lack of time that there is to
prepare it there is
the potential that uh about your scheme
uh
maybe the best option but as i say it's
a little bit too early unfortunately to
be able to give much more detail because
there is quite a lot of work still
going into working out the eligibility
criteria and
uh and what uh sort of what
what options we actually have in terms
of delivery to to residents
um i hope that's a useful update as i
say
i can't provide much more detail than
that because it just simply isn't isn't
there that it isn't there yet but
um as soon as it is i will happily share
it with uh
with viper and obviously uh group
leaders can then cascade it out to
to their groups and i would like just
just a final point about i would like
the district council to pay an active
role
in supporting um supporting the county
and
other stakeholders to to help deliver
this scheme
um so so i'm looking at ways in which we
can involve the districts in particular
and the parishes
to help us to help us deliver that
scheme
thank you chair thank you council dale
council shipman do you wish to withdraw
your money well i was going to say if if
council dale's going to amend it and
bring it in line with what we're
actually doing would it be
wise just to move this as is with
council dale's amendment and then get
members to vote
through that work i mean i think
at least it shows commitment that the
district council's obviously thinking
about the issue
and i think it probably does that work
uh if i might chairman to avoid
confusion it would be useful to move and
second the motion
for cancer dale to move the amendment
and have that seconded
yep okay thanks chair um in that case
i'll move this um
um motion obviously like i say i think
it's it's there's a lot going off the
county council's doing a lot of work the
district council's already doing a lot
of work behind the scenes
i think if we pass something today and
just show our commitment that we know
that we know it's an issue um and that
we are committed along with all the
staff
to ensuring that we play a key role in
delivering some support to the most
vulnerable in the northeast derbyshire
so i move the
amendment as a whole i'm sorry the
emotion as a whole
so do we have a second to chair i'm
happy to second chair i'll
i'll reserve the right to speak
obviously to let alex move his amendment
thank you
okay
counselor dale yeah thank you jay um
i think uh governance have uh
have a sort of copy of the the motion as
amended
uh that hopefully they can share on the
screen so i'm happy to
uh to talk through that okay i think i
think can everyone see that
um sim the only change in the first
section so that's to leave that largely
as it is
um but i think it was reference where
the first
red bit was to the summer holidays and i
think actually
that i mean unless i'm misreading that
sentence my
my interpretation was that the decision
not to extend the free food bachelor
scheme was actually over the october
half turn so that was just a
clarification point but the council's
welcomes bit is an additional
section is just to note the fact that
the government has now announced this
this this recent grant and the county's
allocation
and then the main uh the main change in
terms of the resolutions is simply to
suggest that
rather than the first point in in
council shipments motion
is to say that we to offer support to
the kennedy council
and commit to working with all relevant
stakeholders across the da across
north derbyshire including the county
council to support the delivery of the
kobe winter grant locally to vulnerable
households
um the latter three points under
under the resolve section uh are things
that we've already discussed at viper
meetings and i'm very grateful to
uh the contributions of all members to
those those meetings around ideas for
what we can do to support
vulnerable residents in the lead up to
christmas so so the points there largely
remain
i think the only additional amendment i
had made was
[Music]
i think it referenced on the second to
last bullet point
to deliver parcels well it's just we're
not quite clear yet exactly what the
what the support that the coburg winter
grant is going to take so i've just
changed that to support to keep that
flexible because it may be
parcels it may be vouchers we don't
really know yet so
um so the so the change there will be
this supplies are greater than the
demand for the service
look at other vulnerable groups to
support
so that's the only that's the changes as
far as
i um would suggest that there would be
appropriate and hope that
uh other members will will be happy to
support
you do we have a second there
counselor armitage
councillor barker
thank you chair yeah yeah i think that's
a fair compromise
and the reason i withdrew my question
because obviously things have changed
uh from when we submitted it uh and and
obviously
alex had reported the vapor meeting uh
what the county council were thinking of
doing and i think that that amendment
sort of makes that commitment like ross
says that that we
we are going to do something just as a
bit of an assad and i'll stand corrected
alex on this one but while
i'm doing a bit of research into my
question which i've not asked
is that that i looked at the observatory
thing for 2018
and and they were 1562 pupils
getting a few free school meals and
that's why i put in the question at 1
500.
and yeah i had something last week from
education department
to say there's now 2569.
well that's another thousand kids in two
years
i hope i'm wrong on that i hope i've
read it wrong but
that's a massive increase in in
pupils getting free school meals over a
two-year period uh
and i just it's just something that come
to me and i it knocked me back a bit
really
uh because that's that's a lot of kids
that are going into free school meals
and i suppose i'd make the point
politically is that when we do come out
of this culvert crisis that we don't
expect the the vulnerable and the the
the one with the lease to pay the most
because
that's how it feels at moment it's it
scared me a bit to be honest that that
we've got that many kids we
that's in northeast army [ __ ] there's a
lot more in in derbyshire itself so
it's a big thing alexa and i will stand
corrected if them figures out right but
just just flagging that up but i don't
support the motion the
amended emotion
counselor dale i'm not sure if i can
come back or is it is it a right to
reply at the end okay can i
remember i'm happy to respond to that
point
at the end i'll wait till the end okay
wait till the end alex wait till then
come through ridgeway
yeah i'm just curious um can i ask who
the stakeholders are are they schools
are they gp
surgeries is it the nhs um
that we talked to because um
i think you know they're the very
important people they're the people that
you'll get the information on who are
very
who are vulnerable not just in children
but
in sort of families um elderly
people that are pale as well so i think
you know it's
i agree with with um everything but i
think
i do agree that we need to look at the
broader picture as well and i just like
to know who the stakeholders are and
that we are involving
all those people to find out who exactly
are the vulnerable people
in need
any other speaker
counselor dale
yeah uh thank you chair um so just just
taking the two
i won't prolong the debate i think i
think it sounds like we're all um
you know relatively happy with the the
amended motion in terms of the the two
questions
uh numbers um
nigel i'm not sure on the actual figures
for northeast derbyshire that's
that the rise uh doesn't strike me as
uh as overtly surprising given that we
have seen a significant rise across the
council
across the county um particularly in
relation to coving
and i'm talking about um you know
additional thousands being added to the
list and that's that's
largely reflective of the fact that you
know that there have been redundancies
through the through the through the
copic crisis and
more people having to correct to claim
um universal credit and
obviously that's an absolute tragedy
that that's that's happening but we're
in this situation nationally and
or globally rather and and we can only
hope that we get a
a a vaccine soon and move forward and
get
get the economy back on its feet um so
that so that's the the numbers situation
i don't know the exact figure but
it wouldn't it wouldn't surprise me if
that's the current figure for north
establishing the increase there
um in terms of stakeholders obviously
that uh
that was in in council shipman's
original
version of the motion so i wouldn't like
to second guess but i think i think
we're referring to
all of those people that council
ridgeway uh referred to as well as the
voluntary and community sector you know
food banks and
and on all sorts of charities that
support
uh vulnerable and isolated people so um
yeah i think i think that's correct and
i'm happy to
uh yeah to move to the vote
thank you
ross uh councilor shipman if you wish to
speak
yeah i'm totally happy with that i think
that where we're currently at
it it matches the situation i think so
i'll be supporting the amendment on the
motion
can we have a show of hands for the
amendment please
and all those who are in favor please
put their hands up
that would appear to be unanimous chair
thank you and then chair in full
completeness
the amended motion the substantive
motion
are there any other speakers
move to vote j
show fans please those in favor
again that would appear to be unanimous
chair
so
barker
[Music]
does that need to move this motion sorry
yes you startled me then i was titled
just before i came to the motion i meant
to ask a beginner meeting when
when do we get sight of the minutes of
this the extraordinary meeting or or not
i thought we might have saw
seen them at this meeting uh you can
answer that in a bit there if you want
i meant to ask at the beginning but i
got excited so
but regarding this motion i just
just moved like that the following from
the council meeting on the 12th of
october
i think several issues were raised
firstly as community leader leaders we
signed up to a code of conduct
which means that we should always
consider our behavior in public meetings
however the main issue in this issue in
this instance
was the editing of the video footage
whilst removing 10 seconds might not
seem a lot
it does lead to the question what can
and can't be edited and who decides
what we are trying to establish with
this motion is a clear principle going
forward really
whilst we do consider con we did
consider having caveats in the motion
it did begin begin to get messy hence we
believe the clearest
the most transparent thing is to have no
editing at all
hence i'd like to move the motion as
printed in the
in on the agenda is that okay i don't
need to
read all that out do i sure
thank you we need a second uh
i'll second that chair um and i just
want to say that whilst they understand
the temptation of editing
um our behavior and council meetings
which may bring the authority into
disrepute
ultimately there's an illness on every
single councillor in this meeting to
uphold the code of conduct
and behave in a way in which they award
residents expect them to
it's not the job of council officers and
it's certainly not a job of any elected
member to decide what is or isn't
or what should or shouldn't be edited
out
of the video or audio footage which has
been
recorded of council meetings there are
not two councillors in this authority
who will have the same definitions on
what is considered to be offensive to
themselves by editing out the footage it
creates many problems
um not least because it breaks the
original link posted out
by the council's social media um
and shared out by residents across the
district but
someone might try the link while the
meeting is happening and then go back at
a later date
and then there's no the because the
link's broken they think that the
footage has been completely removed
if they're not willing to go into
youtube to actually look at
um whether it's still there or not on
the council's youtube profile
but the main problem for me is that
residents will never know what is edited
out
of the council meetings if we're going
down that route and because of this
that's going to result in the loss of
trust of those watching because they
don't know whether they're watching the
live meeting whether they're watching an
edited version
um and you know things can easily be
taken out of context when you start
editing videos even if it's just a small
snippet
now the aim of of the policy to remove
parts of the video so it doesn't bring
the council
distribute is an admirable one but
that can only be tackled by there being
a policy that deters people
from behaving in a way that people might
consider to be offensive
and the way you deter people is by video
recording the meetings
and putting that behavior on display so
people are deterred from doing it
now this motion sets in stone what
should have always been the case in my
opinion
it sets out that no footage will ever be
edited by this authority
truly holding all of the councillors to
account for their actions in the in
these meetings
and i've second this motion
wholeheartedly that we should never be
editing any footage whatsoever
of that council's meetings subcommittees
and whatever else thanks cher
does anyone else wish to speak
council cornwall
councillor birkin
um agree with everything that's been
said and i just want to say
to um councillor alex dale that was your
first meeting
as a leader and under your watch
one we've had no minutes of a meeting
two some of your counsellors were
disrespectful
and three
your meeting got edited and as you all
as being a leader
i don't think you've done very well as
your first meeting
that's it councillor birkin
thank you chair um chancellor shipman
just said and reminded the doll it's the
onus of councillors
to uh mind their behavior and to be
respectful
uh of other members i think
unfortunately that was sadly lacking
during that meeting that we're talking
about but i believe as well it's the
onus of the council
to show complete and transparent report
of the proceedings
and i don't think it's for uh any
counsellor or any officers
uh to make the decision what should or
should not be left
uh uh available for the public to see
um i understand or i've been told
that the reason for the um removal
of offensive material because that some
people uh
may feel offended by it and also that
you two
might have cut it out of their um
repeating of our meetings again that is
not for
anyone within the council officers or
members
however senior they may be to make that
decision
unfortunately um i'm sure we've all seen
i know i have
all seen much worse on youtube and
facebook
um there seems to be a degeneration some
would say
uh into uh bad and offensive language
but again that's not for us to make that
decision uh if i see something like that
then i stop watching
that site wherever it might be um so i
think again
uh this shows a lack of respect
uh across the board for uh fellow
councillors and uh
and that bad behavior should have been
shown uh and then for the public to make
their mind upon it
not for anyone to take that decision so
again i um
wholeheartedly support what councillor
shipman and councillor barker
are proposing with this motion thank you
chair
thank you councillor pickling
thank you chair um yes i i agree
it's not for um officers or any elected
members of this council to decide what
the public
sees from the public part of the council
meeting
um you know it's not open and
transparent government
to be cutting things out that we don't
particularly like or wish i hadn't
happened it had happened and the
electorate has the right to see
how their elected members are performing
in the council chamber what their
attitude is
and and how they behave
and councils up and down the country now
record and if you look at any number of
them
i've got one example from dorset
about the protocol for filming an audio
recording of public council meetings
and it quite explicitly says in there
that those recording proceedings do not
edit the film or record in a way that
could lead to misrepresentation of the
proceedings
which this has done it's pretended
something hasn't happened
or infringed the core values of the
council this
includes refraining from editing an
image of views expressed
in a way that may ridicule or show lack
of respect towards those being filmed or
recorded
i think that's quite clear a statement
about what should be shown
from one local authority if we can't
determine a set of principles for
ourselves
we should look to other authorities
about what they mean by open and
transparent government
it's shameful that we've done that and
that recording should be put back into
the public domain in its original state
thank you councillor renwick
just think we have to ask ourselves is
it really in the public interest
and i don't really believe this council
should be in a race to the bottom to be
the worst of the youtube they've ever
seen
i i completely disagree with this motion
vote against
thank you councillor dale
thank you chair um i think i was asked
directly so just to respond to
uh councillor cornwell's uh question
i i don't think she could have been
paying too much attention to the
the minutes of the last meeting because
uh
my first meeting as leader of the
council was back in july and then we've
had september as well
so the october meeting was not the first
i mean in terms of the issues raising
with the motion
um i think we would all agree that
transparency
uh is very important but the the motion
itself just isn't reasonable in its
approach i think we have to accept that
in the
sort of new age of digital meetings we
are seeing more mistakes being made
uh not just in council meetings but
across the board in business
uh also in parliament as well we're
seeing um
mistakes like these being made and we
know that youtube
um could have taken the whole video down
i think councillor burkin referred to
them just clipping the video themselves
they wouldn't have done that they would
have taken the whole video down
right um and in which case that would
have been a much worse state of affairs
because
in terms of transparency because the
public wouldn't have been able to watch
any of the meeting while they while
they're taking it down
um i think it's entirely reasonable for
the monitoring officer as part of her
role
to have taken the decision to do what
she did and we shouldn't allow her
latitude to do so
i think particularly as only 10 seconds
of the video was removed
and none of the debate was removed not a
single item
or any discussion or any members
comments during the actual debate itself
was removed and nor were nor were the
indications of any members vote
removed from the meeting nothing of any
substance in that meeting was removed i
think we have to accept
that there may be future occasions where
a video may need to be edited it's not
just due to mistakes that are made
but in in there are examples where
councillors
are not necessarily this council but
where councillors have revealed
confidential
or sensitive information during the
public section of the meeting
inadvertently
and what if for example a member here
were to start referring to the
experiences of a constituent
and then name that person well under
data protection rules alone
surely it would be necessary and fair to
that person to have the ability to edit
out their name or any other details
which would disclose who they were i
understand that
standards committee are already
beginning work on
a protocol for the issue of video
recordings of council meetings
and i think it's entirely appropriate to
allow that committee
to decide on a sensible and pragmatic
way forward
and for these reasons our group will be
voting against the motion
thank you chair thank you
councillor hancock thank you chair
um i mean i have a particular interest
in this scene as four years ago i
actually first brought this to the
council to ask for meetings to be live
streamed
um i'm i'm very very concerned about
councillor dale's comments that he's
just made
because one of the key things that
councillor faker when he took leadership
of this
this council and council dale supported
at the time
was that we would be absolutely open and
transparent
and there are all i will sit here and
there are times i've said things and i
think oh i wish i'd said that
differently or i wish i'd not said that
and i think if every single one of us is
completely truthful we will all say
exactly the same thing the thing is
the public has an absolute right to see
what we do
what we say and how we react and i think
any kind of censorship is totally
unacceptable
the point that council raised about
things being said which shouldn't be
the chair is the one responsible for
dictating the flow of the meeting and
the chair will stop that
if that happens that is the proper
process
we we passed this we brought this in so
that the public could see what happened
in this council chamber
and i'm sorry in no way shape or form
should we ever be editing
and in regard to youtube taking the
whole thing down i've
seen videos that contain language far
far worse than was actually said in this
council chamber
and they have not been taken down the
only time youtube takes things down
is when there's a copyright infringement
um
and counselor renwick is shaking her
head now
she supported transparency when it was
when it was working in her favor
so i'm sorry she's she's
she's really just turning on the heels
now to try to try and take this back
i i absolutely support the motion and
i'll be backing it fully
i'd just like to reply for me we're
talking about
a word there's no counselor very much
shouldn't be speaking she's already
spoken i believe
chair i want to defend
thank you party boardroom she can give a
personal explanation chair
she's not doing that though councillor
foster yeah
barker do you wish to exercise your
right to reply
already finished uh
i'm not prolonging it i think we've made
the point uh
it is like i said that what we did
consider caveats about they could do
this could do that and then
you'll end up with more reasons why you
can edit it than one you can't and i
think the principle
uh is that uh that
that video it stays in its entirety and
it's up to people to make of it as they
wish
uh so i'll just move to vote please
thank you
thank you
how many do you need three three
i'll agree to that again
that's four sorry
we've had three councillors we need to
call the recorded vote
i will call out your names in turn
please forgive me if i call out somebody
who isn't here
um i haven't necessarily got all the
apologies i will ask
for against abstain please can you be
clear which you are saying
um amy allen are you okay you ready uh
yes
yes i am
so councillor p right
councillor b right not here not here
councillor p winley
councilman response
council whitehead
we're against council welton
against council thakur
again councillor tate
against councillor stone
he's had to leave right councillor
shipman
cancer row against council ridgeway
for council renwick
against councillor reader
against councillor pickering
or councillor parking
against councillor morley
that's a molly
councillor lilly said what was
councillor morley's vote
i think he's trying to indicate with his
hand four
that's a morally four councillor lily oh
councillor liggett against council lewis
against councillor kerry four
that's a kenyan against
councillor jones four
councillor hutchinson against
councillor huckabee against
councillor holmes
councillor hill
council hill
no indication she's left i think okay
councillor hartshorn or
councillor hancock or council hall
councillor gomez rini against
councillor for
councillor mark foster against
councillor angelique foster against
councillor evans against
councillor elliot against
cancer dayton against cancer dale
against councillor cupid
again council cornwall
councillor cooper for councillor clough
against councillor pat bone
against councillor k bone
against that's the birkin for
councillor barry apologies
councillor barker
could i vote for please i missed my vote
i couldn't get the mute off
quick enough is that council winley it
is yes
mine's four thank you
very just why i didn't know can you
answer me question when will we see the
minutes of that meeting
um yeah my apologies are not here it
will either be at the
um extra meeting that council referred
to in his comments
or it will be at your next schedule
meeting in february
okay thank you can i
ask can i ask when we do receive those
minutes
will there be vibration
minutes are a record of the meeting they
are not verb invading as to what was
this
so they will be the usual minutes you
type of minutes you
quite received to to get verbatim
minutes
from that meeting because we can view
the video
foreign
the result is 18 4 with 28 against
and no abstentions
the motion amended is defeated
exclusion of public i move that the
public be excluded from the meeting
during the discussion of the following
item of business
to avoid the disclosure to them of
exempt
information as defined in paragraphs one
and two
part one of schedule 12a of the local
government act
1972 as amended by the local government
access to information variation order
2006.
i have a secondary
second gen
thank you we'll now vote
can we have a show no there's no to vote
on you
sorry
show of hands please
excuse me what are we voting on honey i
don't know
the exclusion republican press well i'd
have i don't think we've ever voted on
that before have we
yeah i thought it was i thought it was a
give no
we have voted on in the past and a
thought and also it is at this point
that the public leaves the recording
so it's good for them to see that you've
actually voted on a motion to exclude
them
well i always thought that in the
chambers excuse me for my ignorance but
i always thought in the chamber the
chair says now the public
go public go we've never voted for it in
the chamber as far as i remember
i've i've seen it done both ways it is a
motion
a vote is appropriate
is that a consensus members that the
public then be excluded
yes okay thank you
um can martin derbyshire confirm when
the live feed is finished
you